اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه والخليج
وهذه ابرز وعناوين اليوم
[موسيقى]
مراسل العربيه يفيد باستمرار المعارك
الشرسه لقوات فيغنار الروسيه شمالي مدينه
الاوروبي المتوسطي يكشف عن زلزال بقوه 5.5
درجات ضرب اليوم وسط تركيا
هيئه الاتصالات السعوديه تعلن عن مبادره
لتعزيز الانترنت السريع في 21 الف قريه
وهجره
من ملفاتنا في الرابعه كذلك
دراسه حديثه تكشف عن اصابه خمسه وسبعين في
المئه من مرضى القلب في السعوديه بالسكري
الداخليه السعوديه تعلن ضبط اكثر من 16
الف مخالف لانظمه الاقامه والعمل خلال
اسبوع
حياكم الله افاد مراسل العربيه بان قوتي
باجنر تخوض معارك في الناحيه الشماليه من
مدينه باخموت بعد سيطرتها على بلده
بيرخوفكا شمالي المدينه فيما تسيطر القوات
الروسيه على هضبات ومرتفعات في المحور
الشمالي الغربي فالقرب من الطريق السريع
الواصل بين مدينه شازوفيا غرباء فيما تشهد
البلدات المحيطه بباخمت معركه محتدمه
سياسيا هدد سفير الروسي لدى الصين بالرد
بقوه في حال امداد كييف باسلحه لضرب عمق
البلاد قبل ذلك اعلن نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي بمترميدف ان بلاده رفعت من قدراته
الانتاجيه في المصانع العسكريه عشرات
المرات وطورتها باحدث التقنيات واضاف ان
روسيا تدرس اسلحه الغرب التي حصلت عليها
كيف كغنائم في الحرب وحذر من ان موسكو
تواجه مره اخرى امبراطوريه من اعداء
مختلفين بعد ثمانيه عقود على الانتصار
الذي حققته في معركه
مشيرا الى ان الخصومه حددوا لانفسهم مهمه
محو روسيا من على وجه الارض بينما اكتسبت
موسكو الثقه في قدرتها على الانتصار
اثارت خطه الصين للسلام التي اطلقتها في
ذكرى مرور سنه على الحرب الجدل ورفعت سقف
الاتهامات بين روسيا والغرب رئاسه مجلس
الاتحاد الروسي اعتبرت ان مبادره السلام
الصينيه كشفت الولايات المتحده على
حقيقتها واكدت ان واشنطن
تستفيدان من الحرب وليس السلام
من جانبه انتقد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
المبادره الصينيه وقال انه لم يرى فيها
شيئا مفيدا لاي طرف غير روسيا فالاثناء شر
بايدن الى انه لا يوجد دليل على امداد
الصين لروسيا باسلحه في الحرب الاوكرانيه
واستشهد بايدن بحديث دار بينه وبين الرئيس
الصيني
حذر خلاله الاخير من العواقب الاقتصاديه
للتورط في الحرب
ليس هناك دليل على ذلك حتى الان
وبالمناسبه اجريت محادثه طويله مع رئيس
الصيني شي حول هذا الامر في الصيف وقلت له
انظر هذا ليس تهديدا انه مجرد كلام عندما
راى الاوروبيون في الواقع ما كان يحدث
وراء الامريكيون ما يحدث في روسيا في
اوروبا خمن ماذا حدث انسحبت 600 شركه لقد
غادروا لا يريدون ان يكون لهم علاقه وقلت
له لقد اخبرتني ان مستقبل الصيني يعتمد
على الاستثمار من العالم الغربي وهذا مهم
قال الرئيس الفرنسي من وين ماكرون انه
سيزور الصين في اوائل ابريل القادم داعيا
بكينا الى المساعده في الضغط على روسيا
لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا كما دعم كرون
ايضا بكين لاجراء محادثات سلام عاجله
اثراء اعلان خطتها لانهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وقال الرئيس الفرنسي ان السلامه
ممكن فقط اذا توقف العدوان الروسي وانسحبت
القوات واحترمت السياده الاقليميه
لاوكرانيا وشعبها
اكدت وزيره الاقتصاد الاسباني ان نهجه
بلادها هو الحفاظ على اللغه التي اتفق
عليها القاده في بالي فيما يتعلق بضروره
وضع حد للحرب في اوكرانيا في اسرع وقت
ممكن
تزداد المناقشات صعوبه مع استمرار الحرب
اعتقد انه من الممكن ان نحقق تقدما في
مختلف القضايا من خلال العمل الجيد
للرئاسه الهنديه وفيما يتعلق بالحرب
وضروره وضع حد لها في اسرع وقت ممكن فان
نهج اسبانيا هو الحفاظ على اللغه التي
اتفق عليها القاده في بالي بحث المستشار
الالماني في العاصمه الهنديه نيودلهي مع
رئيس الوزراء الهندي الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا وطرق تعزيز التعاون الاقتصاديه
تعد هذه المشاهدين اول زياره رسميه يقوم
بها شوتس الى الهند وتستمر ليومين
بالرغمين من ان اجتماعه هو الرابع مع
الوزراء نارين درامودي منذ توليه منصبه
عام 2021 ومن المتوقع ان يضغط شورت للمضي
قدما في اتفاقيات التجاره الحره
والاستثمار في الهند والاتحاد الاوروبي
بعد توقيعهما في مايو الماضي سلسله من
الاتفاقات الثنائيه التي تركز على تنميه
المستدامه التي ستحصل الهند بموجبها على
عشره مليارات وخمسمائه مليون دولار من
المساعدات بحلول 2030 لتعزيز استخدام
الطاقه النظيفه
لدينا بالفعل علاقات جيده للغايه بين
الهند والمانيا وامل ان نعزز هذه العلاقات
الجيده للغايه ونناقش بشكل مكثف جميع
الموضوعات ذات الصله بتنميه بلدينا ولكن
ايضا من اجل السلام في العالم وهو امر مهم
وفقا لاستطلاع مركز الابحاث الاجتماعيه
يوغو في الالماني فقد اشارت نتائج
الاستطلاع الى ان اكثر من 50% من الالمان
يعتقدون بان امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه يجعل
برلين طرفا في الصراع بينما اعرب في الوقت
نفسه سبعه وثلاثون في المئه من المستطلعه
ارائهم عن وجهه نظر معاكسه وراى اربعون في
المئه من الالمان ان برلين زودت كييف
بالكثير من الاسلحه وفقط 22% اشاروا الى
ان دعم برلين العسكري لكيف صغير جدا في
مقابل
23% يرون ان الدعم الالماني العسكري
لاوكرانيا كافن
نعود الى الاوضاع الميدانيه في الشرق
الاوكراني ويلتحق بنا من دونيتس كمراسل
العربيه رائد الاغبر رائد مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
اولا نريد ان نعرف اي المحاور التي تقاتل
الان فيها قوات فاجنر شبه الرسميه الروسيه
وايضا المحاور التي سيطرت عليها حتى
اللحظه
بالفعل قوات باقنر يعني تحيط او تطوق
مدينه باخمه من ثلاث جوانب الناحيه
الجنوبيه والناحيه الشرقيه والناحيه
الشماليه من الناحيه الشماليه
تسيطر على عده بلدات بعد ان اكملت السيطره
على بلده بريخوفكا وتقدمت الى بلده ياجد
نايا وهناك معارك ضاريه في بلده اياغدنا
كما انها تسيطر على الهضبات والمرتفعات
المحيطه
بالاتجاه الشمالي من مدينه باخموت مناطق
اريخ مناطق دوبابا هذه المناطق لم تدخل
منها الى عمق المدينه قوات فاجنر حتى الان
من الناحيه الجنوبيه بالفعل دخلت عده
كيلومترات وهناك مناطق سكنيه كبيره سيطره
القوات القوات فارغنر تحديدا على مجمع
سكنيين وتتقدم في الشوارع الاهليه او يعني
الشعبيه في تلك المناطق الناحيه الجنوبيه
او اذا صح التعبير هي الجنوبيه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه هناك معامل تعليب اللحوم وايضا
مناطق سكنيه تقدمت ودخلت عده
القوات الخاصه قوات فاجنر من تلك الناحيه
ووصلت الى حي غطوطنا ومن ثم الى شارع
شيدره يدعى شارع شيدرا هذه المناطق اطراف
مدينه باقمت في العمق من الناحيه الشرقيه
التطويق ليس كاملا لان المنطقه الغربيه ما
زالت مفتوحه على المناطق التي يسيطر عليها
الجيش الاوكراني تحاول قوات باجنر اكمال
الطوق من الناحيه الشماليه حول طريق الذي
يوصل الامدادات الى مدينه باغموت هي تبعد
كيلو متر واحد عن هذا الطريق في بلده
تتقدم القوات الخاصه الروسيه من اجل
السيطره على مدينه اكراسنا ومن ثم السيطره
على الطريق السريع طبعا هذه التقدمات كلها
مغطاه بحضور قوي للمقاتلات الروسيه التي
لا تتوقف عن التحليق في سماء المنطقه
وكذلك المدفعيه الروسيه التي تقصف دون
توقف منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر وخلال
الايام الماضيه هناك
عمليات عسكريه كبيره خاصه في المحور
الشمالي وهو محور مدينه باقر رائد ما الذي
يعني بالنسبه لقوات فاغنر للجيش الروسي
السيطره على على هذا الطريق السريع وما هي
اهميته ايضا كذلك في تطبيق في تطبيق ايضا
كذلك حتى بلدات وقرى مهمه مثل يعني برخوفك
التي سيطرت عليها شمل المدينه
السيطره على كل شبر وكل عده امتار من
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني
هي تعتبر تقدم ويعني نجاح في العمليه
العسكريه للجانب الروسي السيطره على مدينه
باخموت او الطرق المؤديه الى مدينه باخ
مثل التي توصل الامدادات تعني ان الجيش
اصبح دون دعم ودون ذخيره وهذا يجعلهم
يفرضون عليهم خيارين اما الانسحاب واما
الاستسلام السيطره على مدينه باغموت بحد
ذاتها هي تعني فتح ابواب للتقدم الى المدن
الكبرى في الشمال في مقاطعه دانيتسكو وهي
كراماتورسك سلافيانس قسطنطين اوفكا
سلافيانس خاصه يعني خلفها نهر سيفرسكي
دانيت وهذا النهر هو الذي عليه محطات
التنقيه وتحليه المياه وهو الذي يوصل
المياه العذبه الى المنطقه منطقه
المقطوعه عنها منذ انطلاق العمليات
العسكريه وحتى الان تضخ المياه
للمناطق وليس للبيوت الى الشوارع ساعتين
كل ثلاثه ايام نايف بالفعل المنطقه تحتاج
الى الوصول او القوات الروسيه تحتاج الى
الوصول الى مدينه صلابيانس من اجل تشغيله
محطه تشغيل محطات المياه وايصال المياه من
جديد الى المقاطعه لكن المعارك محتدمه
ايضا في محاور اخرى اليوم
اعلنت السلطات هنا سيطرت القوات الروسيه
في المحور الشمالي الغربي في مدينه
مارينكا على مناطق جنوب المدينه ويعني
تقدمها في شارعين احدهماغي روي شرنوبل
والاخر دلينا تتقدم بعده يعني مناطق ربما
تكون بسيطه لكن الاعمال العسكريه هنا يعني
تسير ببطء شديد لكن المراقبون والخبراء
يرون بان التقدم وان كان ببطء فهو نجاح
للعمليه العسكريه من دوله مراسل العربيه
رائد الاخبار شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
في ذات الملف قالت رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه
ان حزمه العقوبات العاشره التي يفرضها
الاتحاد الاوروبي على روسيا ستعمل على
استنزاف ترسانتها الحربيه والاضرار
باقتصادهم واضافت فوندر لاين في تغريده ان
الاتحاد يكثف الضغط على من يحاولون
الالتفاف على العقوبات الاوروبيه على
روسيا
هذا وفرض الاتحاد الاوروبي عقوبات على سبع
شركات ايرانيه بسبب دعمها لروسيا قبل ذلك
اعرب دينيس كوميتات المتحدث الرسمي باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا عن قلقه ازاء
التحركات المتزايده بعيده المدى للسياسه
النوويه التي تنتهجها ايران مشددا كذلك
على ضروره تجنب اي تصعيد نووي كما ادان
المتحدث الالماني الدوره الاشكاليه الذي
تلعبه ايران في المنطقه في دول مثل سوريا
والى حد ما العراق مشيرا الى ان النظام
الايراني لا يرد على الضغوط الشعبيه
للانفتاح سوى بسياسه القمع الوحشي والتعسف
والعنف ولم يترك للحوار والتفاوض اي مجال
[موسيقى]
مركز رصد الزلزال الاوروبي المتوسطي بوقوع
زلزال بقوه 5.3 درجه على مقياس ريختر وسط
تركيا فيما لم ترد تقارير على الفور بشان
وقوع خسائر نتيجه الهزه الارضيه في الوقت
ذاته اعلنت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه ان الزلزالا بنفس القدر الزاويه
نيدا جنوب البلاد ياتي ذلك بعدما ارتفعت
حصيله ضحايا الزلزال في تركيا الى ما يزيد
على اربعه واربعين الف قتيل
من غازي عنتاب ينضم الينا زيدان زنكلو
مراسل العربيه زيدان مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض نريد ان
نعرف اولا اين ضرب هذا الزلزال الجديد وسط
تركيا اي المناطق التي ضربها وكذلك هل من
معلومات حول خسائر ماديه او بشريه ايضا او
اصابات
الزلزال ضرب ولايه نيدا في وسط الاناضول
هذه الولايه قريبه على مقربه من ولايه
قونيا في اطراف ولايه نيدا شعر بهذا
الزلزال سكان طبعا نيدا وقونيا ومرسين
وابنا كان هناك حاله من الهلع والخوف في
مرسين شاهدنا فيديوهات لنزول العشرات من
المواطنين الى الشوارع خوفا من الزلزال
ومن هزات ارتداديه طبعا الهزات الارتداديه
لم تتوقف خلال الليله الماضيه سواء كان في
سواس او في ملاطيا او في كهرمان مرعش وهذا
اليوم في نيدا طبعا عدد الهزات الارتداديه
التي اعقبت الزلزال المدمر في السادس من
فبراير تجاوزت
9100 هزه ارتداديه طبعا اعداد اعداد
الهزات كبير ومن المتوقع استمرار الهزات
الارتداديه خلال الفتره الفتره القادمه
طبعا بالعوده الى هنا الى غازي عنتاب او
قبل ان ننتقل الى غا لم تسجل افات خلال
المسح الاولي وهي طبعا هيئه الطوارئ
والكوارث التركيه لم تسجل اي اضرار بشريه
حتى الان يتم تقييم الوضع هناك في نيدا
حيث كانت مركز الهزات الابتداديه بالعوده
الى هنا في غازي عنتاب هنا في غازي عنتاب
في منطقه نورداغ حيث نتواجد الان بدات
رسميا اعمال اعاده الاعمار او وبناء اعاده
بناء اعاده الاعمار وبناء منازل جديده
لمتضرري الزلزال في هذا الموقع الذي
نتواجد فيه الان نايف بدات شركه الاسكان
التركيه المعروفه اختصارا باسم توكي عمليه
اعاده اعمار المناطق المتضرره اعاده
الاعمار بدات بشكل رسمي هنا في نورداغ وفي
اصلاحيه في هذه المنطقه
سيتم بناء 855 وحده سكنيه ومن المنتظر
تسليم هذه الشقق لاصحابها خلال سته اشهر
طبعا هذا هذا المشروع السكني هنا ضمن
مشروع للحكومه التركيه لبناء اكثر من 272
الف وحده سكنيه في الولايات ال 11
المتضرره على الا تتجاوز اعداد الطوابق في
البناء الواحد اربعه طوابق طبعا هذا
المشروع حيث يتواجد الان هو بقرب مشروع
اخر لشركه توكي بداته قبل عام بالضبط في
السادس والعشرين من فبراير عام 2022 كما
تشاهدون المشروع السابق شارف على الانتهاء
هذا هو الشكل النهائي للمشروع او المساكن
الجديده التي سيتم بناؤها لمتضرري الزلزال
ابنيه لا تتجاوز اربعه طوابق بعيده عن
اماكن الصدع في مرتفع يطل على بلده نورداغ
ايضا فيه مساحات خضراء وايضا حدائق
للاطفال
بالعموم كما ذكرت رسميا نتحدث عن بدء
عمليه اعاده الاعمار في نور داغ طبعا
بالنسبه
يعني مساكن مؤقتا بشكل سريع
لا هذا المشروع هو مشروع سابق قبل الزلزال
حسب ما تراه
نايف نعم نعم قبل الزلزال لكن شكل الابنيه
ستكون على هذا الشكل بالضبط تقريبا
ساعود بالكاميرا او تعود الصوره الى اعمال
الانشاء بالتوازي مع اعمال بناء المساكن
الجديده التي نتابعها طبعا
هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه والسلطات
التركيه تحاول الان انشاء مساكن مؤقته او
حاويات في 130 نقطه طبعا حاليا هناك تم
ارسال اكثر من 300 الف خيمه الى المناطق
المنكوبه لكن هذه الخيم هي حل مؤقت لحين
الانتهاء من المساكن المؤقته او ما تسمى
بالحاويات والكرفانات
خلال الايام التي لا تزال المدمر في تركيا
تحدثت او تحدث عده ظواهر لا يوجد لها
تفسير اخر تلك المظاهر الغريبه ما حدث في
مدينه قونيه التركيه حيث رصد سكان منطقه
الرشاديه حفره عملاقه تشكلت فجاه تبلغ
مساحه هذه الحفره
1400 متر بعمق اثني عشر مترا وقطر 37 مترا
ما اثار المخاوف من ارتباطها بالزلزال
والهزات التي تضرب ولايات تركيه عده على
مدى الاسبوعين الماضيين
[موسيقى]
تواصلوا قوافل ومركز الملك سلمان الاغاثيه
التوافد عبر المنافذ الحدوديه السوريه
لمساعده المتضررين جراء الزلزال حيث وصلت
اخر تلك القوافل عبر معبر الحمام قرب
جنديرس باربعين واربعين شاحنه وهي الاكبر
التي تصل من المساعدات السعوديه وتتضمن
القافله التي تعد الاكبر من المساعدات
السعوديه لسوريا حوالي 25 طنا من المواد
الغذائيه المتنوعه
[موسيقى]
تعيش عشرات الاسر النازحه من الفئه الاشد
فقرا حياه ماساويه بالقرب من مجرى السيول
في مخيم المجهايه بمنطقه الضباب غربي
مدينه تعز وتعتمد غالبيه تلك الاسر عفوا
الاسر النازحه على عمليه التسول لجلب
الغذائي منذ ان هجرتهم هجرتهم الميليشيات
الحوثيه قبل اعوام من منازلهم من مناطق
ارباعي وحذران غرب المدينه
ويتهدد حياه هذه الاسر السيول المتدفقه من
الجبال الى جانب المجاعه والفقر التي
يعيشونها
ليس في المنزل ما يؤمن معيشتها ليوم واحد
سوى ماء تغليه على النار لصناعه الشاي
هكذا بدا وضع الحجه واليه مع مئات الاسر
المهمشه النازحه في مخيم المقهايه بمنطقه
الضباب في تعز بعد ان هجرتهم الميليشيات
الحوثيه من منازلهم في الربيع غربي
المدينه تهجير دفعهم للعيش في مجلس سيول
بحال معيشي اسوا من ذاك الذي يعيشه فقراء
البلد
يعيشون الخوف والمجاعه منذ خمسه اعوام من
التهجير اكثر من 300 اسره نازحه في المخيم
هذا فقط تعتمد غالبيتها على التسول لجلب
الغذاء اما البعض منهم فياتون بقوت
اطفالهم يوميا من مكب النفايات
معذبين عندنا
لا انا الف ريال نقدر نشتري بروتين واحنا
على المقلب على هذيك التنكه والحبه السفري
معذبين وعندنا لبطانيات جالسين بيوت الناس
هكذا اذا وقبل ان تضعهم ميليشيات الحوث في
الحال الماساوي هذا عمدت على استهدافهم
بطلقات ناريه باغتتهم ذات ليله الى
المنازل فقتلت وجرحه العشرات ووضعت اخرين
منهم في اعاقه دائمه
ولا نوم وصابتنا باليد وبالراس تمام
وقالت يمكن سنتين الان مع شوف ولا اشتغل
الحان نفسه يطال الاف النازحين الذين
هجرتهم الميليشيات الحوثيه من منازلهم الى
مخيمات الضباب والبيرين والكدحه ومقبنا في
ريف تعز الغربي
بالقرب من مجرى السيول اذا تعيش اكثر من
400 اسره يمنيه في منطقه الضباب حياه
معيشيه صعبه بعد ان هجرتهم مليشاه الحوث
الانقلابيه منطقتي الربيع وحذران غربي
المدينه حياه يفتقرون فيها لابسط مقومات
العيش كالماء والغذاء والدواء هل سعيد
العربيه تعز
الرابع مستمره وفي بعد قليل ايضا
دراسه حديثه تكشف عن اصابه 75% من مرضى
القلب في السعوديه بالسكري
حياكم الله من جديد في السعوديه اعلنت
هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه عن اطلاق
خدمه الانترنت عالي السرعه والتي تغطي 21
الفقريه وهجره حول المملكه لضمان
استمراريه خدمات الاتصالات لاكثر من خمسه
ملايين نسمه هيئه الاتصالات اوضحت ايضا ان
خدمه الانترنت عالي السرعه جاءت امتدادا
لمبادره التجوال المحلي التي تتيح التنقل
بين الشبكات من مقدمي الخدمه دون فرض رسوم
اضافيه
اترى برنامج الدعم السكني المحدث في
السعوديه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اثارت تساؤلات عديده حول اليه تطبيقه
والاستفاده منه بالاضافه لتاثيره على
اسعار العقار وحسب برنامج سكني فان دعم
الجديد يتضمن تقديم دعم مالي فوري غير
مسترد يصل الى 150 الف ريال بالاضافه الى
الدعم العيني على الوحدات السكنيه تحت
الانشاء بجانب تحمل الدوله لضريبه
التصرفات العقاريه عن المواطن للمسكن
الاول بما لا يتجاوز مليون ريال
ومعنا من الرياض المحلل العقاري خالد
المبيض سيد خالد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه حياك الله تساؤلات كثيره
حول هذا البرنامج الدعم السكني المحدث ما
الذي يمكن ان نعرفه اولا عن اليه التطبيق
وكيف يتم الاستفاده منها ايضا بسم الله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله اول شيء
اشكر لكم هذه الاستضافه الكريمه
وارجو من الله ان نقدم شيء ينفع الجميع
الحقيقه هو فعلا ما كان في الحقيقه في
بدايه الاطلاق ما كان في وضوح وكان في
حقيقه محاولات كثير من بعض العقاريين
للحديث عن هذا
الدعم ولكن بعضهم لم يوفق
فهذا اللي خلى يمكن في نوع من الضبابيه
عند كثير من الناس طيب لكن هو بكل بساطه
الحقيقه هو عباره عن امرين الامر الاول هو
اصبح اكثر ذكاء في عمليه استهداف الاكثر
احتياجا من ناحيه طبعا دخل الشهري كل ما
قل دخ لك الشهري الى تقريبا اقل من 10,000
ريال في كل ما اقل كل ما زادت قيمه الدعم
بمعنى اللي رد اقل من عشره الاف كم كم
ما زادت يتم عمليه التقليل قيمه الدعم هذا
الامر ولا اعتقد طبعا انه الامر الاول هذا
ايجابي لانه عمليه تحديد الفئه المستهدفه
بشكل اكبر
وتوجيه السيوله لها هذا يضمن استمراريه
الدعم لانه تعرف هي في النهايه ميزانيه
اذا صارت دعم يعني عشوائي للجميع بكافه
فئات الدخل سيكون هناك يعني قضيه في
الاستمرار طيب هذا هذا اول جانب الاخر
واعطى خيارات فقط
اعطاك خيار انك انت تحصل على هذا الدعم
مقدما يصل الى 150 الف ريال الدعم المفروض
تاخذه على مثلا على فتره التقصير لانه هو
فعليا الدعم هو يدعم
الفائده عنك يعني يسدد عنك الفائده لصالح
البلد فهو خيرك بين انك انت تاخذها كمبلغ
مقدم حوالي 150 الف يبدا من 150 الف ريال
اذا كان طبعا دخلك 3000 ريال في اقل بحيث
انك تستفيد منه في الدفعه الاولى وبالتالي
يقل عليه تكاليف الاقساط او يكون على شكل
اقساط شهريه
الى 1350 ريال شهريه
سيد خالد هل تسمعني سيد خالد
سيد خالد هل تسمعني يبدو انه انه في
ايقونه موجوده في السكايب عندك فتمنع انه
اي احد يتدخل في اثناء حديثك يعني انت ما
كنت تسمعني انا كنت اسال قبل قليل اولا عن
اللي راتبه اقل من عشره الاف ريال ما هو
الرقم الذي يستفيد منه من خلال هذا الدعم
السكني المحدد واللي راتبه كذلك ايضا اعلى
من عشره الاف ريال كيف كيف راح تتاثر هذه
العمليه وبالتالي تنعكس على سوق العقار
على الاسعار على المعروض ايضا وكذلك على
الطلب ايضا طبعا هذا سؤال جيد انا اعتقد
انه اول شيء اللي راتبه 3
000 كامل المبلغ وهو اما يختار بين 150
الف ريال ياخذها مباشره
لكي تساعده في عمليه الدفع الاولى او يحصل
على اقساط 1350 ريال شهريا مستمره معاه
الين يتم سداد قيمه القرض المدعوم اللي هو
ال 500,000 طبعا كل ما زاد راتبك كل ما قل
تدريجيا الى ان يصل عشره الاف طبعا اذا
صار راتبك اكثر من عشره الاف تحصل فقط على
ميزات الدعم في الفائده اللي هي تحمل
الدوله لضريبه التصرفات العقاريه راعي
جميع الفئات الان على سؤالك كيف يتم
الاستفاده او كيف سيكون شكل القطاع
العقاري بعد هذا التطبيق هذا النظام انا
اعتقد انه سيكون ايجابي على هذه الفئه
لانه المطورين العقاريين سيبدا ينظرون
لهذه الفئه اللي هي فئه اللي تحتاج منزل
350 الف ريال الوحده يعني الى 500 الف
ريال طبعا هذه في السابق كانت يعني منسيه
من قبل المطورين العقاريين لانه كان الدعم
موجود لجميع فئات المجتمع وبالتالي كان
لهم خيار انهم يختاروا اي فئه فبالتالي
اكيد المطور العقاري سيختار الفئه الاكثر
دخلا لتوفير وحدات سكنيه من مليون ريال
فما فوق اليوم سيكون هناك
يعني يعني فرص لهذه الفئه لكي يلتفت لها
المطورين ليبنو وحدات سكنيه سواء كان في
مدن رئيسيه في الضواحي يعني
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الرياض المحلل
العقاري خالد مبيض شكرا جزيلا لك
كشف للعربيه البروفيسور السعودي في جامعه
الملك سعود واستشاري قسطره الشرايين
والصمامات محمد البارقي كشف بان امراض
القلب في السعوديه تصيب الاشخاص بشكل ابكر
عن الدول الاخرى بما يصل الى نحو عشره
اعوام بالاضافه الى ارتفاع نسبه المصابين
بالسكري من مرضى القلب وهو ما يشكل خطرا
مضاعفا البروفيسور البارقي اضاف بان نسب
الاصابه بالسكري لا تزال مرتفعه في
السعوديه مقارنه بالمعدلات العالميه
ومعنا بروفيسور في جامعه الملك سعود
استشاري قسطره الشرايين الصمامات الدكتور
محمد البارقي دكتور محمد مساء الخير حياك
الله معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض خلينا
نعرف اولا لماذا لا تزال نصب النسب
الاصابه بالسكري في السعوديه مرتفعه جدا
مقارنه بالمعدلات المتوسطه عالميا
اول شيء شكرا على الاستضافه بالنسبه
السكري في المملكه العربيه السعوديه من
اعلى نسب في دول العالم يعني عندنا في كل
في كل مئه شخص 29 الى 30 شخص منهم صعب
السكري ونسبه ثانيه نسميهم بريده يعني
للاسف مهيئين انه يصابوا بامراض السكر
المجتمع تعرف يعني شكله فتره والى الان
للاسف انه نسبه السكر زايده ومعها نسبه
السمنه زائده الحركه قليله فهذه الاشياء
بالاضافه الى العوامل الوراثيه والجينيه
فاغلب العوائل للاسف في المملكه
بما فيها عوائل الاطباء فيهم مرض السكر
دكتور
الانراض القلب في السعوديه تصيب الاشخاص
كما ذكرت بشكل
ابكر جدا من من الدول الاخرى بما يصل الى
نحو عشره اعوام لماذا السعوديه لديها يعني
هذا هذا الامر ايش المسببات ايضا
وهل بامكان
وهل بامكاننا مثلا ان نقلص مثلا هذه
الفتره تصبح بذات المعدلات العالميه
هي النسبه الاعلى في الاصابه
بتصلب الشرايين او الذبحه الصدريه ايضا
كما ذكرت ولمرتبطه ايضا كذلك بامراض
السكري
لا ننسى انه مريض السكر مهيا يكون
الكوليسترول عنده مرتفع يكون عنده لا سماح
الله ارتفاع كذلك في الضغط الدم
السمنه للاسف زي ما قلنا مفرطه عدم الحركه
الان الحمد لله في وعي الدوله ما بتقصر
يعني وزاره الصحه المستشفيات العسكريه
المستشفيات الجامعه كلها المستشفيات هذه
تحاول تزود الوعي نسميه اويرنس انه في
مشاكل انتبهوا لها تغيير اللايف ستايل كيف
تعد لحياتك كيف تعدد اكلك يعني كل هذه
الاشياء مهمه جدا نسبه الكوليسترول
الوراثي في دول الخليج من الدراسات حديثه
في دول الخليج حنا اكبر نسبه كولسترول
وراثي في العالم هي دول الخليج ومنها
المملكه ممكن تكون على راسها في عده عوامل
تشتغل مع بعض مش عامل واحد فقط يعني يا
دكتور اليوم احنا
حتى نخفض من معدلات الاصابه بامراض القلب
نحتاج الى الى الى مجتمع يكون يعني معدلات
الاصابه فيه بالسكري منخفضه هل هذا ما
افهمه منك
[موسيقى]
نعم مجتمع يبغى له يغير الحياه حقته نمط
الحياه يعني نبغى نمشي اكثر نحاول
نحفظ على نحافظ على نوعيه الاكل الوزن عده
اشياء للاسف شديد واحده من الاشياء اللي
تزعلنا انه الدخان للاسف انتشر في جيل
الشباب بين الاولاد والبنات اكثر من اول
بكثير وهذا عامل مهم درجه انه في فتره
الشتاء اغلب الناس اللي يجونا بجلطات
القلب عن طريق الطوارئ وندخلهم قسطره
للاسف ترى اعمارهم اقل من 30 سنه يعني في
ليله واحده سوينا يمكن ثلاثه كلهم اعمارهم
بين الثلاثين والاربعين هذه الاشياء ما
تشوفها بر
دكتور خطوره الاصابه بالسكري وقسطرت
شرايين
الشرايين والصمامات ايضا حتى دكتور هل
هناك نسبه معينه
الخطوره موجوده احنا قلنا الخطوره عامه
30% في المجتمع السعودي تزداد مع قله
الحركه تزداد اذا كان السكري موجود في
العائله وعندهم مشاكل قلبيه فهذا الشخص
اللي عنده مشاكل قلبيه في عائله معرض لا
سمح الله انه يصابه في نفسه فعشان كذا
التاليه يا دكتور احنا عندنا 30% من
المصابين بامراض السكري في السعوديه هم
بالضروره مصابين او لديهم قسطره للشرايين
ولديهم انسداد في الصمامات
[موسيقى]
عندهم قابليه او قابليه قابليه تصير عندهم
مشاكل اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
الرياض بروفيسور جامعه الملك سعود استشاري
قسطره الشرايين والصمامات الدكتور محمد
الباري شكرا يا دكتور
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل ايضا
الداخليه السعوديه تعلن عن ضبط اكثر من
سته عشر الف مخالف لانظمه الاقامه والعمل
خلال اسبوع
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد علينا وزاره الداخليه
السعوديه القبض على اكثر من 16 الف مخالف
لانظمه الاقامه والعمل وامن الحدود معظمهم
من مخالفين نظام الاقامه بنحو
9500 مخالف الداخليه السعوديه كذلك كشفت
عن ضبطها نحو سبعه وثلاثين شخصا لمحاولتهم
عبور الحدود الى الخارج بطريقه غير نظاميه
يجري حاليا اخضاعهم لاجراءات الترحيل
والاحاله لاستكمال اجراءات السفر
يواصلوا معرض بنالي الفنون الاسلاميه
والمقام في صاله الحجاج بمطار الملك عبد
العزيز بجده استقبال زواره حيث يقدم لهم
اكثر من 200 وثمانين قطعه اثريه معاره من
مؤسسات محليه ودوليه واعمال الاربعين
فنانا كذلك يقدم تجربه تفاعليه لزواره عبر
منصه تفاعليه للحجاج القادمين من دول
العالم
مراسل العربيه سلطان السلمي سلطان مرحبا
بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض ماذا
لديك في معرض بنالي جده
اهلا بك نايف واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه نتواجد حاليا في معرض بناء للفنون
الاسلاميه وتحديدا من صاله رقم خمسه هذه
الصاله التي تسمى بصاله المدار نتحدث على
اكثر من 280 قطعه اثريه تحت سقف هذه
الصاله وضعها بطريقه مبتكره وبطرق عرض
مختلفه نتحدث عن قطع هي اصليه ومعظمها
تعرض للمره الاولى هنا في معرض بينال
الفنون الاسلاميه قبل الخوض في تفاصيل هذه
الصاله والقطع الموجوده نتحدث انه حتى هذه
اللحظه منذ افتتاح معرض بينال الشهر
الماضي نتحدث على اكثر من 200 الف زائر
زارو هذا المعرض نتحدث على اكثر من 26
جنسيه تواجدت داخل هذه المعرض نتحدث على
الزيارات مستمره من عدد كبير من المدارس
والاكاديميه المهتمين في الثقافه والفنون
الاسلاميه بشكل عام هذه الصاله عدد كبير
من القطع القطع نتحدث على كثير من قطع
الاعمال اليدويه وسجاد وغيرها من القطع
الخشبيه النادره والفخار والمنحوسات
النادله تعود تعود تاريخها الى عده قرون
ماضيه
تحكي تاريخ العالم الاسلامي قديما نتحدث
انه 280 عاما هي اتيه من عدد قرابه او
تحديدا 23 دوله تم جلب هذه القطع منها
وعرضها في صاله رقم خمسه تحديدا صاله
المدار هنالك معارض شخصيه وكذلك قطع تم
جلبها من متاحف ودور عرض اسلاميه في عدد
كبير من الدول الاسلاميه تم جلبها خصيصا
والبعض منها للمره الاولى يعرض هنا في في
معرض بناء ايضا من الطرق العرض الذكيه
استخدام التقنيه عاليه الدقه الدقه
والذكاء الاصطناعي في للاطفال تحديدا
والكبار ايضا من خلال يشاهدون هذا الصاله
والمعلومات التي يتم عرضها كل قطعه يتم
عرضها هنا في هذه الصاله والصلاه الاخرى
كذلك يتم وضع شرح خاص لها على سبيل المثال
هذا السلم الخشبي الذي يعود الى ما قبل
250 عام وهو سلم لباب الكعبه وهو المره
الاولى يعرض هنا في معرض بنلي كذلك هنالك
قطع من الاحجار النادره وغيرها من
المنسوجات والكتب وغيرها كذلك من المؤلفات
القديمه التي تعرض في معرض
لقيت هذه الصاله زميلي نايف اهتمام كبير
من قبل المهتمين والمثقفين وكذلك الزوار
لمعرفه تفاصيل الفنون الاسلاميه قديما
وكيف كان شكلها وكيف كانت تفاصيلها وطريقه
عملها ايضا نتحدث انه وجود المرشدين او
المتخصصين الذين يرون لكافه الحضور هذه
التفاصيل وهذه الاعمال التي تعرض لمرت
للمره الاولى هنا في
معرض بنالي للفنون الاسلاميه كذلك نتحدث
انه الاشخاص الفنانين المتواجدين في
المعرض بشكل عام نتحدث على الجنسيات
مختلفه شاركت من اقصى الشمال الى اقصى
الجنوب يتحدث على دول اوروبيه ملكه من
العالم الاسلامي شاركوا بالقطع التي
يملكونها وغيرها من التفاصيل المهمه ايضا
اليوم هنالك توافق بين القطع يحكي حقب
زمنيه مختلفه حتى تاريخنا الحالي لذلك هذه
الصلاه تعرض القطع منذ وقت قديم الى وقتنا
هذه الحاضر بشكل ذكي وسلس للحضور بشكل عام
نعم اشكرك جزيل الشكر من جدا ضلينا مراسل
العربيه سلطان السلمة شكرا يا سلطان
مسرحيه معلقات امتداد وامجاد المسرحيه
الاولى من نوعها في السعوديه شهدت اقبالا
واسعا من الجماهير في اول عرض لها بمشاركه
ابرز نجوم الغنى نشاهد
مسرحيه معلقاتنا امتداد امجاد مسرحيه
غنائيه احتفاء بيوم التاسيس في عمل فني
غير مسبوق بتنظيم من هيئه المسرح والفنون
الادائيه وذلك على مسرح جامعه الاميره
نوره في الرياض
[موسيقى]
المسرحيه هي عباره عن مجراه للمعلقات
العشر الشهيره في الشعر العربي حيث تستعرض
تاريخ وامجاد المملكه العربيه السعوديه
منذ تاسيسها الى الزمن المعاصر بمشاركه
مجموعه من ابرز نجوم المسرح في الغناء
[موسيقى]
اول شيء احب اهني خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ولي عهد الامين
الامير محمد بن سلمان بمناسبه يوم التاسيس
السعودي
وعسى الله يدينا يديم الامن والامان علينا
يا رب العالمين
ويديم حكامنا ويطول باعمارهم يا رب
العالمين شعورك اليوم مشارك في هذه
المسرحيه مسرحيه معلقات
[موسيقى]
ودور كبير ودور اساسي
وسعيد اني اشتغل حبيب قلبي
هذا اول عمل يجمعني مع الفنان فؤاد عبد
الواحد
اشتغل معاه وتعرف المعدن المعدن الطيب
وهذا الشخص من المعادله غير انه فنان
اسطوري طبعا يعني
وجوده اضافه كبيره للعمل يعلم الله الله
يحفظك
[موسيقى]
اقبال كبير على شراء التذاكر لحضور
المسرحيه والتي تعد الاولى من نوعها حيث
تم تدشين العرض الاول وتبقى عده عروض خلال
الايام المقبله حتى تاريخ 27 فبراير في
قناه العربيه محمد خالد الرياض
تعد مزارع ونخيل النرجيل الاستوائيه والتي
تنفرد اظهار جنوب سلطنه عمان بتواجدها من
اهم عناصر الجذب السياحي كما تحظى باهتمام
حكومي كبير بهدف في تنميه القطاع من خلال
زياده المساحه المزروعه
[موسيقى]
كتاب الرابع بابرز عناوينها
مراسل العربيه يفيد باستمرار المعارك
الشرسه لقوات باجنار الروسيه شمالي مدينه
الاوروبي المتوسطي يكشف عن زلزال بقوه
5.5 ضرب اليوم وسط تركيا
هيئه الاتصالات السعوديه تعلن مبادره
لتعزيز الانترنت السريع في 21 الف قريه
وهجره
ودراسه حديثه تكشف عن اصابه 75% من مرضى
القلب في السعوديه بالسكري
داخليه السعوديه تعلن عن ضبط اكثر من 16
الف مخالف لانظمه الاقامه والعمل خلال
اسبوع
شكرا لكم المتابعه زميل خالد مدخل يلقاكم
غدا في الرابعه ونترككم في رعايه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]